Land und Brecht
[Musik]
schönen guten Morgen Richard guten
Morgen Markus jeder heute morgen ein so
lustiges Erlebnis bin wach geworden mach
mein Telefon an
einen Post von den Kollegen von Terra x
history darauf siehst du Helmut Kohl und
dazu die Überschrift lädt dieser Post
langsamer wegen Helmut Kohl
und ich musste so lachen weil wir auch
gelegentlich leitungsschwierigkeiten
haben und dachte genau und lädt auch
unser Podcast gelegentlich langsamer
wegen Helmut Kohl da wird die schöne
Geschichte aufgedröselt dass ja die
Regierung Schmidt
1981 beschlossen hat dass Deutschland
bis 2015 also Westdeutschland mit
Glasfaseranschlüssen ausgestattet sein
soll und heute sind wir was
glasfasanschluss angeht ganz ganz ganz
ganz ganz weit hinten weil Kohl lieber
das Privatfernsehen gefördert hat und
hat dann in ganz großen Stil Kupferkabel
verlegen lassen und zwar ohne Leerrohre
dazu ja die heute den Ausbau deutlich
erleichtern würden das nicht was mit
Schwarz Schilling zu tun ja das wird
immer erzählt der der berühmte so eine
Firma Sonnenschein oder wie die hieß
kurz bevor Minister wurde seiner Frau
überschrieben hat also er war es war auf
jeden Fall so ich habe ihn auch mal kurz
danach gefragt und
mit Bausch und Bogen zurückgewiesen aber
die das Gerücht ist das war eine Kupfer
Kupferkabel Firma und dann wird er
Minister und plötzlich werden
Kupferkabel verlegt statt Glasfaser
genau
die Kollegen von Terra x history
allerdings spekulieren darüber dass das
was mit Leo Kirch zu tun hatte
der Ausbau des Privatfernsehens und
diese ganzen Kabel weil
Kirch hat davon vor allen Dingen
profitiert
jüngeren Zuschauer noch mal erklären wie
hoch
ein Dutz Freund von Helmut Kohl von dem
Kohlen nach der Kanzlerschaft für
vermeintliche Beratertätigkeiten 1,8
Millionen DM ohne nachweisbarer
Gegenleistungen bekommen hat ja also ein
riesiges Imperium aufgebaut hat
ursprünglich Filmhändler richtig ne also
der der lieferte den Sendern die Filme
und hatte die die rechte da dran ja
bestimmt auch deine Lieblingsserie Väter
der Klamotte
was meinst Du mal auch
alles alles
Privatfernsehen in Deutschland quasi zu
werden mit seiner riesigen Firma richtig
und er ist dann irgendwann politisch
sehr hoch gestiegen quasi also durch
durch Begünstigung und dann aber auf
brutalste Art und Weise zur Strecke
gebracht worden richtig genau und dieser
Leo kriege ich meinst du ist der Grund
warum das mit den Glasfasern nicht kann
ja das ist also der hat auf jeden Fall
enorm davon profitiert von diesem nein
das ist jetzt ging einfach darum das
Geld sozusagen anders einzusetzen ja und
ähm Kohl hatte ich einmal weißt du ja
auch ne der hat ja immer Stress mit mit
öffentlich rechtlichen investigativen
Formaten Panorama und Monitor und so das
ging immer alles auf dem Geist die sind
ja auch offen Zeiger gegangen
genau also man kann den den Grill gut
verstehen aber das ist so ein bisschen
die die die Vermutung ich finde es nur
heute interessant weil wir gleich ich
wollte heute mit dir mal über Indien
reden ja du hast ein tolles Gespräch
neulich zu zum Thema gehabt kommen wir
gleich dazu und das ist ja ein Land das
hightech-mäßig auf dem wirklich auf dem
Sprung ist wenn man sich die Zahlen mal
anguckt Glasfaseranschlüsse
Südkorea was schätzt du wie viel Prozent
die sind sicher ganz ganz weit
Deutschland
ja okay ach ich denke das irgendwie
komplett 100% oder 87 also fast genau äh
Schweden was schätzt du auch weit
skandinavischen Länder große Entfernung
wenig Leute aber
viel Glasfaser viel Glasfaser das sind
ja 80 pass auf Chile 61
er hat viele ist ja das Land des Kupfers
fällt mir gerade einen richtigen
Produzenten wahrscheinlich auch noch
schwarz Schillings Kupferkabel verlegen
so Türkei
boah ich weiß dass Erdogan unglaublich
in die Infrastruktur investiert hat so
wurde den Autobahn wegen Datenautobahn
50% 28 immerhin finde ich und wo liegt
Deutschland
[Musik]
15 Prozent 8
oder das ist das ist also deswegen lädt
dieser Podcast langsamer wegen Helmut
Kohl
wirklich ich musste so lachen
gratulieren die Kollegen das sind eine
herrliche Händler hat mir heute morgen
wirklich hat den Tag gleich ganz anders
starten lassen wunderbar Richard Indien
es ist was historisches passiert
also mehr als 1,4 Milliarden Menschen so
genau weiß das ja kein ich habe in der
Schule gelernt es gebe in Indien 750
Millionen Menschen zu deiner Zeit war
das auch wahrscheinlich richtig also das
ist natürlich jetzt eine halbes
Jahrhundert her aber seitdem fast
verdoppelt überlegt mal so also in den
letzten 40 Jahren müssen sie sich
verdoppelt haben ja es muss irgendwie so
gewesen sein das war die zweite hat die
inneren im Schnitt Kinder bekommen fünf
weißt du wo die heute sind ist übrigens
interessant und daran siehst du was sich
da getan hat also auch demografisch
wahrscheinlich jetzt auch bei drei
runter oder so bei zwei zwei
irgendwas eine gute Nachricht ja das ist
also nicht dass ich nicht den Kindern
gönne dass es immer mehr werden sondern
wegen des berühmten über
bevölkerungsprobleme wieder zeigt wieder
wo Wohlstandswachstum darauf wollte ich
hin da geht die Kinderzahl runter
richtig und das die Prognosen sind es
wird dann irgendwann bei 1,7 Milliarden
sich einpendeln und dann geht's runter
aber es ist wirklich interessant darüber
überlegst also
1,4 Milliarden in das sind mehr als
dreimal so viele Menschen wie in der
gesamten EU leben ja das sind mehr
Menschen als alle Einwohner von Nord und
Südamerika zusammen das bedeutet fast
jeder fünfte Mensch auf dem Planet ist
ein Inder oder Chinese weil die liegen
ja knapp dahinter richtig das heißt also
zusammen ja jeder zweieinhalb der Mensch
ist Inder oder Chinese eben überleg mal
deswegen das asiatische jahrhundert ohne
jeden Zweifel so die größten Märkte ja
noch riesiger aufholen Bedarf genau
nicht zu vergessen Indonesien auch
zunehmend als Wirtschaftsmacht Bedeutung
kriegt und auch ein starker
Bevölkerungsentwicklung kann genau
auch interessant hat mit ranga Yogeshwar
darüber gesprochen dieser Tage der sagte
im Jahre 20 30 gibt's ocd-schätzungen
werden ungefähr 27% aller
Wissenschaftler weltweit wenn es Indien
kommen
37% aus China und wie viel aus
Deutschland
sehr gut 1,8 1,8 und um halt so die die
Dimension mal klar zu machen ne also die
staatliche Eisenbahngesellschaft Indien
railways kürzlich wie viele Lokomotiven
bestellt bei Siemens
1200 Lokomotiven einfach so
wahrscheinlich so viele wie in
Deutschland insgesamt waren ich glaube
mehr als 1000 ja wenn sie fahren wenn
sie fahren soll die die Airline er India
hat kürzlich den größten Flugzeug Deal
ihrer Geschichte gemacht
250 Flugzeuge bei Airbus bestellt und
knapp 300 Mal Boeing das musst du dir
mal vorstellen du bist überlegen was
wäre die Weltwirtschaft ohne China und
Indien so
mit Abstand nicht dieses Wachstum gehabt
und diesen Wohlstand hier wenn wir die
nicht unglaublich von diesen Märkten
profitieren und immer noch ne also ein
immer mehr immer immer
obwohl die USA wie die her investieren
mehr und mehr und mehr in China richtig
also während auch der politischen Ebene
gesagt wird aufpassen und dürfen uns
nicht abhängig machen läuft ökonomisch
exakt das Gegenteil genau das der Punkte
das ist diese seltsame
Widersprüchlichkeit und ich ich habe es
in so einem Kontext gestellt ich finde
es das gleiche wie bei der Deutschen
Bahn ne also wie versichern uns seit
Jahrzehnten ständig gegenseitig wir
müssen dringend jetzt die waren ausbauen
und was sie wird ist immer miserabler ja
das ist passt nicht zusammen und wir
haben noch vor ein paar Jahrzehnten das
ist verrückt haben wir im Jahr 4
Milliarden Euro die Deutsche Bahn
gesteckt und mittlerweile waren wir
kurzzeitig mal runter auf eine Milliarde
jetzt geht so langsam wieder hoch auf
zwei das heißt diese vermeintliche
Verbesserung wir haben jetzt da mehr
Geld im Metall ja von von 1 Komma
irgendwas hoch auf zwei ist in Wahrheit
immer noch nur die Hälfte dessen was wir
hatten also das ist das Projekt keiner
das will eine ganze Sendung über die
Deutsche Bahn macht eines meiner
Lieblingsthemen nicht nur als Benutzer
das ist ein schönes Kapitel dramatischer
fehlerentwicklung er ist ist richtig
deswegen lass uns lieber über Indien
reden 1200 neue Lokomotiven finde ich
super das Land der Start-ups die
IT-Branche auch total interessant ja
indien hat mittlerweile 100 sogenannte
Einhörner ja Unicorns also Unternehmen
mit einer Bewertung von mehr als einer
Milliarde Dollar das ist wirklich
beeindruckend und dann auch so Sachen
und hat mich damit beschäftigt total
interessant also Datenschützer
hierzulande die die die den willst kalt
den Rücken runterlaufen fast alle in der
haben inzwischen so eine komische
laberige Plastikkarte und darauf sind
gespeichert ihre Fingerabdrücke und
biometrische Daten nee ja genau aber das
bedeutet ja wie immer sowohl als auch
das heißt bedeutet Millionen Menschen
können sich damit zum ersten Mal
wirklich identifizieren ausweisen ja und
ohne Ausweis hatten all diese hatte
vorher keine Möglichkeit einfach mal ein
Konto bei der Bank zu eröffnen das
interessant heute hat ein Großteil aller
Erwachsenen eines dieser Konten und da
gibt es andere Sachen zumindest
Sozialleistungen können dadurch dann
direkt überwiesen werden das heißt der
Staat kann sich nicht nur Bürokratie
sparen sondern das Geld kommt dann auch
wirklich bei den Betroffenen an war
früher auf der Fall das wurde von
irgendwelchen Mittelsmännern einfach so
dann eine Korruption abgezweigt war das
heißt die Leute das heißt wenn du so
jemanden fragst ob er
ein Thema mit seinen Daten hat oder ob
ihm die pünktliche und auch ausreichende
Überweisung seiner Sozialhilfe lieber
ist kann mir vorstellen
also dass man um Zugang und Anteilnahme
und Ansprüche zu haben Freiheit
einschränken muss
schon
Janusköpfigkeit
auch faszinierend nicht da habe ich das
Gefühl das ist ähnlich wie wie bei den
Chinesen einer der Gründe sagen Leute
die sich damit auskennen warum die
chines so unfassbar schnell plötzlich in
diese Digitalisierung reingekommen sind
ist ja das ja die laptopphasen noch so
erlebt habe die haben ja übersprungen
direkt sozusagen aufs mobile Endgerät
direkt auf die Apps direkt auf aufs
Handy und das passiert gerade in Indien
auch mittlerweile Systeme
sie ist so ein Milliardär am Start
nilekani heißt der hat dann
Zahlungssystem geschaffen können jeder
Inder heute bin in Sekunden Geld von
einem Handy auf das nächste
transferieren und zwar komplett
gebührenfrei ja also eine unglaubliche
Technologie Gläubigkeit ich glaube ich
würde mich in dem Land gar nicht mehr
zurecht finden
Geld eigentlich mit Sicherheit ja klar
warst du mein Indien nee
ich habe mal für eine Reportage in im
Süden in schennai gedreht ich meine
Indien ist ja kein Land sondern es ist
ein Kontinent ne das ist einfach
gigantisch groß und ich erinnere mich
noch an diese unvorstellbare schwule
Hitze die macht dich wirklich fertig und
ich erinnere mich an dieses laute
wuselige in diesen Städten für jemanden
der gerne fotografiert wie ich natürlich
also Wahnsinn der erste Weltbund und
laut und lärmlich und
dann hast du überall diese Straßenstände
und dann gehst du hin und sagst ich
hätte jetzt gern mal ein Brötchen
irgendwie und sagt er ja mit mit
Hühnchenfleisch und so weiter und sagst
ja sehr gerne mit Hühnchenfleisch und
dann fällt dir auf hinter diesem Tresen
gackert es irgendwie in so einer Kiste
und plötzlich hört das geht gar nicht
auf und dann weißt du jetzt kommt gleich
dein Brötchen mehr
weil die Abwesenheit von Kühlschränken
natürlich dazu führt dass du das
Hühnchen einfach so am Start haben
möchte das ist sehr beeindruckend und
wir haben damals der Reportage gedreht
über über indische Mädchen die auf dem
Land
bis heute zum Teil
umgebracht werden und zwar nach der
Geburt auf es gibt sieben oder acht
verschiedene Arten und Weisen wie diese
Kinder umgebracht werden weil ein
Mädchen für viele arme Familien
tragischerweise eine große Belastung
darstellt mit Gift die Mitgift wird in
Gold ausbezahlt und das können sich
viele arme Familie nicht leisten und
dann spielen da Hebammen und Großmütter
und so weiter eine ganz traurige Rolle
bei dieser Geschichte mit Müttern dort
gesprochen ist das zerreißt dir wirklich
das Herz und ist ein großes Tabu ist
auch schwierig mit jemanden sich darüber
zu unterhalten Indiens tote Töchter ich
glaube gibt es noch in der Mediathek war
damals ein
sehr sehr berühren dafür Film und das
ist mir wirklich Kopf geblieben und auch
wie wie die Dinge so Zusammenhängen ne
also damals habe ich verstanden wenn wir
hier mit Gold spekulieren und der
Goldpreis geht nach oben dann bedeutet
das in Indien ist ein Mädchen jetzt in
großer Gefahr weil auch dort der
Goldpreis steigt das sind so
Zusammenhänge die du dann plötzlich
verstehst und wo du merkst okay da in
diesem ganz abgelegenen Dorf in Indien
auf dem Land
es schlägt plötzlich die Globalisierung
für die Spekulation richtig das ist
wirklich hart wenn man das dann mal so
so begreift aber abgesehen davon ähm was
du auch immer siehst ist diese
Lebensfreude und dieses wollen ja dieses
verliebt sein ins gelingen ähm diese in
die die wirklich jetzt merkt okay es ist
jetzt unser Moment und du hast neulich
Richard ein tolles Gespräch zu dem Thema
geführt da habe ich mir angeguckt weil
die innerhalb
was wie hast du den erlebt was berichtet
er also indischer Schriftsteller
Philosoph ne ja
Kulturhistoriker Schriftsteller der
meinen sehr erfolgreiches Buch
geschrieben hat das Zeitalter des Zorns
in dem er versucht hat die Wurzeln des
Terrorismus zu erklären vor einigen
Jahren sehr gutes Buch dazu okay was ist
die These naja gut bringt es natürlich
mit der Kolonialgeschichte in Verbindung
und dass der der Terrorismus von den
Terroristen selber immer noch in der
Tradition das kann man ja das muss als
Freiheitskampf empfunden wird ja gegen
Besatzer die
welthegemonie aufgebaut haben und die
dann nichts mehr verloren haben das ist
sozusagen deren Selbstverständnis ist
und das interessante hat zuletzten Buch
geschrieben in erster Linie eigentlich
über die Engländer und die die englische
Kolonialgeschichte und er wirft den
Engländern vor dass sie ihre
verbrechensgeschichte nicht adäquat
aufgearbeitet haben im Vergleich zu den
deutschen genau also er lobt Deutschland
sehr ich habe auch in der Sendung gesagt
das war natürlich für Deutschland auch
keine Frage eines anderen Weges also
Deutschland hatte den Krieg verloren das
interessant und in Deutschland gehört
neu nachdenken richtig ihre Werte ihre
Moral ihre Rolle in der Welt und Sieger
tun das im Regelfall nicht und
Großbritannien war halt Sieger im war
zwar letztendlich Verlierer des Zweiten
Weltkrieges und Deutschland Gewinner
wirtschaftlich gesehen aber militärisch
was umgekehrt das heißt also im
Großbritannien musste nicht irgendeine
Kontinuität aufgebrochen werden und man
müsste dann völlig neues
Selbstverständnis eine neue Moral
entwickeln man muss sie sich nicht
hinterfragen genau
das heißt also ihre
verbrechensgeschichte gegenüber den
schwarzen gegenüber der indigenen
Bevölkerung und so weiter musste nie im
vergleichbaren Stil aufgearbeitet werden
und ist deswegen als latenter Rassismus
ja auch noch vorhanden wie die Deutschen
das gemacht haben und das ist das was
bankascha
sehr bewundert hat und sagt also wenn
wenn alle Völker des Westens sich so
benehmen würden wie die Deutschen und so
um ihre Geschichte umgegangen wären dann
werden wir heute viel weiter
er sagt aber dass die ehemaligen
Kolonialmächte Frankreich England in
gewisser Hinsicht die USA das nie getan
haben und das ist deswegen so schwierig
ist dass der Begriff des Westens Länder
zusammenbringt die einen sehr sehr
unterschiedlichen Umgang mit ihrer
eigenen verbrechensgeschichte pflegen
und dass man verstehen muss dass es in
Ländern die unter der Kolonialzeit
gelitten haben wie zum Beispiel Indien
ja eine sehr sehr starke Abneigung gibt
sich vom Westen was über Werte erklären
lassen zu wollen das gleiche gilt auch
für China was ja im Prinzip auch
Englisch Kolonie war und dass das Dinge
sind die man verstehen muss wenn man mit
diesen Ländern umgeht
und ein Punkt noch der ihm wichtig war
wir sprechen heute in letzter Zeit ganz
ganz verstärkt vom 21 Jahrhundert als
Kampf der Demokratien gegen die
Autokratie und er sagt das stimmt ja so
nicht einfach schon aus der meinen Grund
es gibt viele Autokratien gegen die
haben wir nichts gegen die Golfstaaten
gegen Saudi-Arabien und so weiter wenn
man das scharf verfassen will dann ist
es der Kampf der etablierten ja also der
USA und der Europäer gegen die empor
können Linge gegen die Chinesen und
gegen die Inder ja die sagen wir sind
jeder zweieinhalb der in der
Weltbevölkerung lebt in diesen Ländern
wir sind aber nicht adäquat vertreten
nicht in der Weltbank im Internationalen
Währungsfonds in der
Welthandelsorganisation und so weiter
sondern das sind eigentlich
Institutionen des Westens und seine
Befürchtung ist dass der Westen nicht
auf adäquate hat und Weise bereit ist
die Früchte des Wohlstandes in dieser
Welt mit den vorkömmlichen zu teilen und
das sagt er wäre sozusagen die Matrix
für die Konflikte in die wir jetzt
reinkommen also das ist jetzt referiert
was sozusagen seine Kernaussage ist
interessant ist sozusagen was das für
eine für eine Welt ist die da gerade
entsteht
dieser Tage gelesen dass eigentlich
diese diese bipolare Welt also Kalter
Krieg also die auf der einen Seite der
Westen ja die Amerikaner im Wesentlichen
auf der anderen Seite die Sowjetunion
dass das eigentlich etwas war
paradoxerweise was zu einer gewissen
Stabilität geführt hat
immer und das aber eigentlich eigentlich
muss man sagen wir hatten auch bis zum
Mauerfall keine ernsthaft bipolare Welt
wir hatten auch damals sehr weitgehend
eine Packs Amerikaner also die USA waren
dem real existierenden Ostblock ja
dermaßen wirtschaftlich überlegen dass
das alles die Jahrzehnte der USA
letztlich waren es waren ja nur eine
Handvoll Länder ja also auf dem
Höhepunkt vielleicht mal 10 oder 15 oder
vietnamen und wie das damals ist und so
weiter Angola Mosambik also wirklich nur
ein paar Länder in denen es Moskau
freundliche Regierung gab und im Grunde
genommen war dass die Zeit der
Globalisierung und des siegesuchtes
Kapitalismus auch schon in der Zeit als
es noch eine Sowjetunion gab und noch
eine DDR
eigentlich kann man zusammenfassen dass
die Zeit nach 45 eben die Zeit war in
der die USA die uneingeschränkte
Hegemonialmacht in der Welt war und wie
gesagt diesen winzigen Ausnahmen
abgesehen und was eben jetzt passiert
ist dass diese Macht bröckelt durch den
wirtschaftlichen Aufstieg asiatischen
Länder und man kann sich auch überlegen
dass da in Zukunft noch andere
hinzukommen Saudi-Arabien
sollte sich der Iran mal aus der
Geiselhaft der Mulas befreien wäre der
Iran auch ein solcher Kandidat Brasilien
steht schon lange
das heißt also das Gefüge verändert sich
und dieser Text von dem du gerade
gesprochen hast diese Expertise für
deutsche
sicherheits-kenner am stabilsten sei die
Welt wenn es ein Hegemon gibt das mag
durchaus so sein zum Beispiel in der
Zeit des römischen Reiches es ist aber
keine moralische Rechtfertigung für
einige
es könnte ja dann jemand anders dran
sein könnte man sagen okay dann ist
jetzt mal China der hegemonde so gut
wenn es nur einen gibt genau ja also so
kann man moralisch nicht argumentieren
nee das ist richtig wobei das ist ja
auch nur analysiert und es ist natürlich
schon interessant wenn man man hört das
so ja ich konsumiere ja dann auch
irgendwie viel weil sie nicht politische
Lektüre und so weiter man hört das im
Radio man ist auf dem Weg zur Arbeit man
kriegt das mit da gibt's diesen neuen
mega Player ja also wenn du überlegst
jeden Monat strömt eine Million in der
neu auf den Arbeitsmarkt dort das ist
ihre wenn du dir überlegst 80 neue
Flughäfen sind dort im Bau also das ist
ein wirklich eine Riese der da gerade
erwacht und verschiebt sozusagen die
Situation was kennt eben sagt ist dass
also man würde ja von außen sagen da ist
doch wunderbar dann geht es einem
weiteren Land jetzt irgendwie gut die
haben auch ähnlich wie die Chinesen die
haben glaube ich vier 500 Millionen
Menschen so aus der Armut geholt aus
bitte das da der muss man in Indien
wirklich sagen ich weiß auch in diesem
Slum damals in Chennai da haben wir auch
auch gedreht und waren da unterwegs da
habe ich das erste mal begriffen was
wirklich leben in einem Slam bedeutet
wirklich denkst okay da ist jetzt
irgendwie noch so ein Kellerloch rein da
werden vielleicht drei Kartoffeln
gelagert nee in dem Kellerloch wohnt
dann plötzlich ein Mensch
schaust du plötzlich in die stahlblauen
Augen einer sehr sehr alten Frau dieses
Foto damals gemacht das habe ich immer
noch vor Augen mich wahnsinnig
beeindruckt und man fragt sich wie
geht's sowas und deswegen ist es erstmal
eine gute Nachricht wenn Menschen aus
solchen Verhältnissen rauskommen sogar
also nicht nur gut sondern das ist also
es ist
größten Leistungen der letzten 50 Jahre
ja gehört das was in Indien und in China
passiert ist genau also unter dem
Gesichtspunkt Menschen wurde dieses
Leben es ist sind das die Länder die am
meisten getan haben aufgeholt haben und
sozusagen die größte Leistung vollbracht
das muss man anerkennen bei allen Dingen
wie man an diesen Ländern auch
kritisieren kann richtig aber dann sagt
kennert eben
vergleichbare Situation in der
Geschichte was kann das bedeuten ja also
vor 100 Jahren zu Beginn des 20
Jahrhunderts drängen plötzlich neue
Mächte sozusagen nach vorne ja das
Deutsche Reich Russland Amerika so und
fordern sozusagen ihr ihr ihre
Mitsprache ein und ihr Recht auf auf auf
auf
entsprechenden Anteil an dem was zu
verteilen ist so der damalige Hegemon
ist Großbritannien findet sich in seinem
Abstieg wieder und das Ergebnis ist am
Ende dieser katastrophale krieg ja und
deswegen ist die Frage wenn man sich das
auch so anschaut was da gerade im
innovazifik passiert ja ich weiß noch
Obama auch wie oft das beschrieben
worden ist Obama hat dann angefangen die
USA plötzlich Richtung Pazifik
auszurichten genau verstanden haben in
Asien passiert jetzt also weg von Europa
dieses dieses alte Europa das war fanden
die alles nicht mehr sexy nicht mehr
relevant
und dann wendest du dich plötzlich
diesem asiatischen Raum zu und ich hatte
eine Zeit lang wirklich das Gefühl und
ehrlich gesagt habe ich das in
Teilnehmer noch mein worauf läuft das
denn hinaus jetzt mit den USA und mit
China ja also wir haben Gefahren fast
zwangsläufig irgendwann auf einen auf
eine militärisch Auseinandersetzung
vielleicht auf einen fürchterlichen
Krieg hinaus und wenn man sich jetzt
vorstellt jetzt kommt noch Indien mit
ins Spiel aber eine super Power die da
plötzlich auf die Weltbühne strebt was
bedeutet das dann vor allem wenn du dann
weißt wie sehr historische Verbindungen
zu von zu Russland auch da sind Russland
wichtigster
Waffenlieferant für die Inder und so
weiter also was bedeutet das
ganze russische Öl ab und so weiter ja
also was das bedeutet ist diese Gefahr
zu erkennen die Gefahr zu erkennen das
tatsächlich die der Übergang also wenn
wenn eine Welt macht bröckelt genau bei
den USA der Fall ist was aber ein langer
Prozess ist das passiert jetzt nicht in
zehn Jahren
wir reden über eine Entwicklung die
jetzt über Jahrzehnte sich ereignet
ähnlich wie das bei dem britischen
Empire eigentlich auch gewesen ist und
wenn man das erkennt was für ein Risiko
in einer solchen Weltsituation besteht
äußerste Vorsicht und Sensibilität das
ist das was ich daraus gewinnen würde
also möglichst alles zu verhindern was
die Konfrontation verschärft in die
Konfrontation ist ja nicht gewinnbar
dann müssen wir nicht lange drüber reden
und abgesehen davon ich meine wenn
tatsächlich China Taiwan attackieren
sollte und sich wieder einverleiben ja
wo niemand weiß ob das wahrscheinlich
oder unwahrscheinlich ist das überhaupt
keine einschätzen kann überhaupt keiner
aber wenn sie es tatsächlich tun wird
ich meine dafür würden wir keinen
Dritten Weltkrieg riskieren dafür würden
auch die USA keinen Dritten Weltkrieg
riskieren ja auch China ist nuklear
macht und so weiter das heißt ich glaube
dass umso lauter gedroht wird
umso klarer einem ist dass man keinen
Krieg führen kann
ja ich erinnere mich daran wie Obama mal
in die baltischen Staaten gefahren ist
nachdem Georgienkrieg glaube ich war das
und dann flammende Reden gehalten hat
die Amerikaner würden bis zum Letzten
die baltischen Staaten und so weiter
schützen und verteidigen und so und ich
gedacht habe klar der redet und bellt
jetzt hier so laut weil er für die
bayerischen Staaten keinen Dritten
Weltkrieg riskieren wird ja genau
deswegen hält man umso lautere
flammendere reden um damit abzuschrecken
weil man weiß dass die militärische
Abschreckung nicht funktioniert im
Zweifelsfall
und deswegen glaube ich ist diese diese
säbelrassel Rhetorik ja im Augenblick so
so ausgeprägt
auch dass man so tut als würde jetzt
eine Auseinandersetzung bevorstehen
zwischen zwei Systemen das ist also das
Denken was ja so aus dem Kalten Krieg
hätten ne Kapitalismus Kommunismus
und das unsere Außenministerin ja auch
gesagt hat China wäre ein wörtliche
Formulierung war ein systemischer Rivale
genau ich ständig die Form ist
mittlerweile so eine frostel geworden
verschieden die nicht also ich auch die
Chinesen missionieren ja nicht also
anders als der Kommunismus ja der seinem
Selbstverständnis nach irgendwann die
ganze Welt beglücken wollt
immer wurde zitiert so in meiner
Kindheit und Jugend dieser Satz aus dem
Kommunistischen Manifest ja das Endziel
des Kommunismus ist die Weltherrschaft
Solingen bei dir zu Hause war immer
Revolution ja nee also das wurde immer
von von von den Konservativen ja gegen
gegen alle linken was meinst du was die
wollen die wollen alles nur erobern und
so weiter Ja und Nein Angriffskrieg nach
dem anderen führen und so also dass man
sagt jetzt geht ja um den Kampf von
Systemen das ist ja nicht der Fall also
erstens ist China wenn man ehrlich ist
kein komponistisches Land sondern
kapitalistisches Land sogar
kapitalistisches kapitalistischer als
Deutschland
immer seit tausenden von Jahren gewesen
aber die missionieren nicht indem die
sagen die ganze Welt muss jetzt so
werden wie China
ja also es interessante ist und ich
finde das kommt viel zu kurz wer
missioniert eigentlich mit seinen Werten
weißt du wo der Ursprung dafür sitzt in
monotheistische Religionen
das Christentum ja stimmt ja Kreuzzüge
ja und früher war die war hieß es nicht
Demokratien gegen Autokratien sondern
Christen gegen Heiden ja und das und der
Islam als die beiden großen
monotheistischen Religion die haben
sozusagen hier breiten uns immer weiter
aus und die anderen sind weniger wert
und so ja und das heißt Anspruch ne ja
das Christentum natürlich ein wichtiger
Teil unserer DNA ist haben wir das
Aufklärung und so weiter beibehalten ja
also diese dieser Mission
missionsanspruch die müssen so werden
wie wir
das haben die Chinesen nicht die
innerlich und zwar jetzt zwei
buddhistische geprägt der Länder wie
Indien kommt da noch der Hinduismus dazu
der eigentlich aus Persien kommt und
diese Länder missionieren nicht ihre
Weltanschauung sondern die sagen wir
können bleiben wir wollen macht das wie
ihr wollt wir machen das wie wir wollen
das lassen wir aber nicht zu und darüber
müssen wir nachdenken warum ist das für
unser Selbstverständnis nicht mehr zu
vertreten dass ein Land wie China einen
anderen Weg politisch geht eben keine
Demokratie ist als wir warum können wir
nicht sagen das ist deren Sache
nicht verstanden warum können wir die
nicht in Ruhe lassen die haben doch ein
Recht darauf ihren Weg zu gehen ich
möchte nicht gerne in China leben ich
bin ein absolut glühender Anhänger
westlicher Werte aber gerade weil ich
das bin würde ich mit diesen Werten
nicht missionieren und rumdrehen
das heißt wenn du jemanden wie Annalena
baerbock dann siehst im picking
also wenn ich ganz ehrlich sein darf
dass ich immer denke was für ein Unfall
dass diese Frau Außenministerin geworden
ist ja also ich nehme an dass die hätte
noch normal am unter normalen
Bedingungen im Auswärtigen Amt nicht
mein Praktikum gekriegt dass jemand mit
so diesem moralischen Inbrunst einer
Klassensprecherin einer Welt macht einer
Kulturnation versucht zu erklären was
westliche Werte sind sie als systemische
Rivalen definiert und quasi ein
eskalationsszenario an die Wand malt
eine Werte geleitete Außenpolitik die
Wirklichkeit eine Konfrontation geleitet
aus dem Politik ist
statt einfach mal kleine Brötchen zu
packen und sich sagen so lange wir in
Deutschland wirtschaftlich erfolgreich
sind neben die Chinesen uns mit allem
Drum und Dran ernst
wenn wir uns aber immer stärker in die
Konfrontation reinziehen lassen und wenn
wir irgendwann die Brücken gar zu China
abbauen würden dann würde unsere
Wirtschaft mehr oder weniger den Bach
runtergehen und zwar ziemlich gewaltig
und dann würden unsere westlichen Werte
erst recht keiner mehr ernst nehmen
die Logik ist nur wer wirtschaftlich
stark ist kann mit seinen Werten
überzeugen und zwar nicht dadurch dass
er andere belehrt sondern dadurch indem
er etwas vorlebt was für andere
nachahmenswert erscheint Werte werden
weitergegeben durch Personen die diese
Werte haben und überzeugen das ist auch
im privaten Leben so wenn jemand dich
belehrt du hättest die falschen Werte
und was weiß ich was sie müssen nicht zu
er ist Kindererziehung
nee jemand der die lebt und den du
bewunderst und den du toll findest dann
bist du empfänglich dafür Werte zu
übernehmen
wir können unsere westlichen Werte von
denen ich sehr überzeugt bin nicht als
Kampfmittel einsetzen und nicht also
Druckmittel ja und nicht als Drohmittel
um anderen zu sagen dass wir moralisch
die besseren sind
wir erreichen genau das Gegenteil von
dem ja am Ende werden wir wirtschaftlich
die Verlierer sein und mit dem
wirtschaftlichen Niedergang auch die
moralischen Verlierer
die ich sehe ja das das sagt dann
Gesprächspartner ja auch ne dass wir
unsere Glaubwürdigkeit verlieren und
sagt auch wenn ich total interessant
je moralischer und moralisierender wir
dort auftreten desto unglaubwürdiger
machen wir uns weil wir ja auf der einen
Seite zwar die Moral dann immer
hochhalten und wie so eine Monstranz vor
uns her tragen um auf der anderen Seite
aber gleichzeitig selbstverständlich
Geschäfte zu machen
das ist in der Tat so und das wissen die
Chinesen auch und deswegen reagieren Sie
darauf mit einer gewissen Gelassenheit
also Werbung ist ja nicht diejenige der
mit angefangen hat zu 20 25 Jahren ja
muss jede politische Delegation die nach
China fährt für die Presse irgendwann
das Wort Menschenrechte angesprochen
haben und das in der Pressekonferenz
zweimal erwähnen die Chinesen wissen das
die Lächeln Schilder drüber ja die
wissen das müssen die deutschen
Politiker und Wirtschaftsdelegationen
für die Öffentlichkeit machen aber die
wissen auch was bedeutet nicht es ist
nur schon weißt du was es ist es ist
Senden nach Hause ja es geht gar nicht
um die Chinesen es geht darum zu Hause
diese Botschaft zu setzen ja also für
mich ist der Inbegriff weiser China
Politik immer Helmut Schmidt
also in der Zeiten von Helmut Schmidt
hat das ja auch angefangen dass die
Deutschen verstärkt in china investiert
haben und China als Absatzmarkt und so
weiter
und so weiter und Schmidt hat immer sehr
bewusst gesagt dass er die westlichen
Werte notfalls auch mit dem Knüppel
verteidigen würde das ist aber nicht
unsere Aufgabe ist andere Länder wie
China zu erziehen oder zu belehren mit
diesem Werten und ich würde mir so
wünschen wir würden zu dieser
Schmidtchen Weisheit zurückkommen und
ich möchte keine Außenministerin sehen
ja die in der UNO den Chinesen droht für
den Fall dass sie Teil waren angreifen
mit was denn
mit was denn da ist diese gerade mal
etwas über 40-jährige junge Frau die in
ihrem Leben noch nichts geleistet hat ja
und droht diesem Land das 600 Millionen
Menschen aus der Armut rausgeholt hat
dass die die rasanteste wirtschaftliche
Entwicklung da hingelegt hat die je ein
Land auf diesem Planeten gemacht hat
ist doch ungesagt war zum fremdschieben
also ich ich verstehe das Argument
Richard ich meine der Punkt ist
natürlich die Tatsache dass sie eine
Frau ist dass sie 40 Jahre alt ist dass
sie vielleicht noch relativ unerfahren
ist und so weiter das ist ja das ist
kein Argument finde ich ne sie spricht
ja in dem Moment für Deutschland und es
geht ja darum wie wir uns als
Deutschland vor Ort und es ist am Ende
eigentlich dann zweitrangig wer die
Botschaft sozusagen übermittelt die
Frage ist ob wir als Land das genauso
vermittelt haben wollen ne dass sie hat
ja interessante Punkt
sozusagen nichts ist ja dann unter
höchst du damit natürlich oder deinen
Glaubwürdigkeit komplett das ist der
Punkt wenn wenn du weißt du Drost jetzt
und am Ende ist das maximale was kommt
ist wir schmeißen mit Watte Bäumchen
oder Spritzen mit Wasserpistolen dann
bringt das halt nichts also die Tatsache
dass sie eine Frau ist es ja völlig
irrelevant ja sonst gesagt wenn
40jährige alter Mann das geht
ja ich meine nur jemand der auf keine
Lebensleistung zurückblickt
das ist nicht unwichtig gegenüber den
Chinesen die eine Kultur der
Altersweisheit haben wo man also erst
ernst genommen wird ab einem bestimmten
Alter und eben demonstrieren muss was
man alles geleistet hat
und das ist in den Augen der Chinesen
wenn man bis dahin relativ wenig
geleistet hat ich will jetzt nicht die
Sünden noch aufzählen ja von gefälschten
Lebensläufen und nicht selbst
geschriebenen Büchern und was weiß ich
was also man hat als Person ja nichts an
Lebensleistung zu bieten das ist aus der
chinesischen Perspektive wenn man solche
Reden macht wo man China droht nicht
ganz unwichtig
dann kannst Du überlegen wie das auf der
anderen Seite wahrgenommen wird als die
ist das einzige was an der grün ist ist
die Farbe hinter ihrem Ohren das ist die
Art und Weise wie das wahrgenommen wird
und deswegen spielt das Alter in diesem
Falle doch eine Rolle das ist nicht
dasselbe ob ein Kind war irgendwie was
sagt ja
sozusagen 100-jährige Mumie sein Leben
aber wenn das jemand ist der der eine
große Lebensleistung vollbracht hat ja
oder schon seit zehn Jahren ein Land
regiert oder ein Statement ist und so
weiter wenn der sowas sagt ist das was
anderes als wenn das jemand macht der
vorher nur Parteipolitik gemacht hat und
gerade mal gut 40 das macht einen
Unterschied
würdest du nicht sagen ich mache jetzt
noch einen Versuch würdest du nicht
sagen und fand es ganz interessanter mit
Kai strittmata
sehr gutes Buch was ich ob du das kennst
die neue Erfindung der Diktatur Kollege
von der Süddeutschen der lange
china-korrespondent war der feiert
Annalena baerbock und sagt höchste Zeit
dass einer mal klar redet weil das tun
die Chinesen ihrerseits auch das fand
ich interessant also jemand der sagt und
das können die auch ab dass das das ist
nichts was die irgendwie großartig
aufregt das können die wunderbar ab
damit können die können die umgehen und
dann wissen die sozusagen woran die sind
also der schätzt das völlig anders sagen
woran sie sind ich meine die das was da
auf der einen Seite auf der Ebene der
Außenminister und das was wir
wirtschaftlich machen sind ja sowieso
zwei verschiedene Dinge deswegen können
die Chinesen das mit großer Gelassenheit
nicht ernst nehmen
ja keine Konsequenz es ja also ich finde
man könnte dann ja es geht ja nie darum
zu sagen wir machen jetzt mit den gar
keine Geschäfte mehr und es findet diese
Handel nicht statt Klammer auf können
wir uns auch mit Blick auf den deutschen
Wohlstand nicht mal ansatzweise leisten
also wenn man weiß was wenn ich jemand
interessant auch in der Sendung bin ich
immer so komme wieder rufe in der Wüste
manchmal bitte und sage was auch von den
großen Konzernen zum Beispiel VW und
andere real ein Drittel des Gewinns er
kommt aus China ja die verkaufen so
viele Autos wie wie Amerika und Europa
von deutschen Firmen produzierten Autos
werden auf dem chinesischen Markt
verkauft so richtig noch in ein paar
Jahren nicht mehr viele sein ja wenn du
dann siehst wie wir bei der
Elektromobilität die in China ein riesen
Thema aus dem Markt jetzt raus ja ich
meinte der Hauptgrund da haben wir uns
schon oft darüber unterhalten warum wir
die große Wände zur Elektromobilität
gemacht haben und in dem Tempo machen
hat mit Umwelt ja nichts zu tun das geht
um den chinesischen Gericht gelesen
machen das auch nicht in erster Linie
aus Umweltgründen sondern in erster
Linie deswegen weil Elektroauto kann
jeder bauen und das kann man sehr sehr
viel günstiger bauen als ein
Verbrennungsmotor Auto und die Chinesen
haben jetzt ja die Idee die die
Deutschen auch überholt
Produktion Elektro VW ist nicht mehr
Marktführer in China das erste Mal seit
40 Jahren muss man sich vorstellen es
passieren gerade wirklich viele viele
Dinge und es ist so interessant dass du
vorhin gesagt hast das geht langsam dass
der Punkt das geht langsam aber es geht
es passiert es findet statt und VW ist
mit Blick sozusagen auf Autoverkäufe
insgesamt immer noch die Nummer zwei
chinesischen Markt Nummer eins ist wie
die machen übrigens nur Ei also
ausschließlich man nur elektronisch
setzen voll auf Elektromobilität und das
interessant ist aber wenn du dir und da
willst dann spannend die Zahlen anguckst
im Bereich eh Autos da liegt VW bei 2,4%
in China das heißt der Tag also
ja genau
ja und das ist das eine bittere
Nachricht und du siehst ja deswegen
finde ich ganz interessant also wenn wir
jetzt gerade über über den Auftritt der
Außenministerin sprechen
wir sehen sie auch an Indien weil wir
heute über Indien ein bisschen reden
Richard und das kam auch in einem
Gespräch daraus
wie schwer wir uns tun uns klar zu
positionieren wie überrascht wir sind
also wie verstört nachgerade wenn wir
dann merken da fährt dann Scholz nach
nach Indien und trifft sich mit Modi der
auch ein interessanter Mann der der
Wahnsinnige Biografie sein Vater hat hat
er einen teestand einen Bahnhof in
Westindien irgendwo das heißt ist ein
Beweis dafür was du im modernen Indien
offensichtlich also Stichwort
Kastensystem dann doch an Aufstieg
schaffen kannst wenn du dich unfassbar
anstrengst hat er offensichtlich gemacht
und daraus resultiert auch ein großer
Teil seiner Glaubwürdigkeit der Sohn
eines tierverkäufers ja aber der und
gleichzeitig natürlich auch muss man
dazu sagen ne eine eine politische
problematische Figur absolut absolut ja
genau nationalistisch bis ins Marke und
so weiter ja können wir vielleicht
gleich noch einen Satz drüber reden ich
denke immer ne also früher als ich klein
war da habe ich immer gedacht man ist
Nationalist oder man ist Kommunist ja so
heute sehe ich das völlig anders heute
denke ich man spielt diese Karten weil
man sie politisch für richtig und
sinnvoll hält genau das heißt also ich
glaube dass die Kinder in dem Versuch
eine moderne Nation zu werden jetzt
gerade in einer Phase ja der
nationalistischen Übertreibung sind
ideologisch
so wie der Konfuzianismus und dieser
lügenkommunismus in China ja sehr
wichtig ist sozusagen für das narrativ
und für die Identität und damit alle
mitkommen und so weiter damit der Kit in
der Gesellschaft verwahrt wird und nicht
weil sie tief in seinem Herzen
überzeugter Kommunist oder Konfuzianer
ist also ich glaube dass diese Ideologie
und
diese diese Weltanschauungen von den
Führern benutzt werden und zwar benutzt
werden weil sie glauben dass es
politisch klug und sinnvoll ist das
einzusetzen ob wir das ob das richtig
oder falsch ist sondern ob die
Einschätzung richtig sind das kann ich
alles nicht beurteilen ich lebe nicht in
China und ich lebe nicht in ihn dir aber
es geht nicht um tief ein gefressene
Glaubensgrundsätze von Fanatikern
sondern es geht bei Weltanschauung und
die Ideologien oder der soziologische
Fachbegriff dafür wäre derivationen ja
also Dinge die Emotionen in der
Bevölkerung in etwas weltanschauliches
um um ein
gemeinsamkeitsgefühl zu erzeugen genau
und das läuft aus einer ganzen Reihe von
Wunden in China völlig anders ab als im
Westen und in Indien noch mal anders ab
aber ich glaube das ist am Ende gar
nicht um Weltanschauungen bei diesen
Dingen geht ja wahrscheinlich ist das so
und weißt ja wir reden ja oft darüber wo
die Ideologie da das Geschäftsmodell
nicht weit ja das sind wir genau in dem
Punkt aber ich fand es interessant wie
verstört wieder plötzlich alle waren als
wir gemerkt haben warte mal
Sicherheitsrat die Inder enthalten sich
die die sind ja gar nicht irgendwie auf
unserer Seite verstehe ich jetzt gar
nicht wer wir bekommen doch jetzt alle
im Moment geben sich ja alle Staatschefs
alle Außenminister jeder der irgendwie
kann alt nach Indien umarmt Modi mal
mehr mal weniger nicht aber man schmeißt
sich da sozusagen ran weil man natürlich
auf diesen gigantischen Markt nicht
verzichten möchte und plötzlich merkt oh
da ist ja nach China jetzt wo es
problematisch wird findet die nächste
große Chance und da kommen wir sehr viel
Geld verdienen und dann merken wir
plötzlich die Inder sind dazu ähnlich
wie Lule auch in Brasilien zum Beispiel
er hatte Scholz ja auch seine
interessanten Moment ja der auch nicht
bereit war klar zu sagen wie verurteilen
diesen Angriffskrieg in der Ukraine und
so weiter wir wir stellen uns ganz klar
gegen die Russen wir haben alle ein
einziges Interesse die wollen den Westen
nicht Stärken richtig sie wollen nicht
dass der Westen aus diesem Krieg als
großer Sieger hervorgeht genau weil das
diese Entwicklung zur multipolaren
Gesellschaft für einige Zeit dämmen
würde ja und und und verlangsamen würde
genau und das ist das Hauptinteresse
dieser Länder
und deren Interesse besteht auch darin
dass es nicht zur einem neuen Vertrag
von Tor desias kommt ja also der neue
Vertrag von todessia es war als ich die
Portugiesen und die Spanier im
Südamerika gekloppt haben und dann hat
in Torte cias der Papst eine Linie an
die Wand gemalt und gesagt das eine ist
eure Einfluss wäre und das andere ist
die andere das heißt sie wollen jetzt
keine Welt aus zwei Einfluss führen die
wollen keine Welt wie wir das Sagen
Demokratien gegen Autokratien ja sondern
warum in Brasilien Portugiesisch und dem
Rest von Lateinamerika Spanisch ist
genau
sozusagen für Jahrhunderte ja eine
zentrale Entscheidung getroffen indem er
gesagt hat jemand die Linie und rechts
davon gehört denen und links von denen
und dass wir wieder in eine Welt
kommentiert war ja auch die Mauer ja das
war ja auch eine Torte sie als Linie ja
genau dasselbe auf der einen Seite
dieses System auf der anderen Seite das
System und wenn wir gucken was die
Herausforderung 28 jahrhundert sind
globale öko-katastrophe Klimawandel und
und und dann durften wir nicht mehr in
dieses wir gegen die Schema zurück bei
Strafe unseres eigenen Untergangs nicht
wir können uns auch nicht leisten jetzt
über Jahrzehnte Turbo Hochrüstung zu
betreiben das ist alles Geld was wir
brauchen um das Überleben der Menschheit
zu sichern also je schneller wir aus
diesem Denken wieder rauskommen umso
besser für die Welt ja ja aber du merkst
ne an diesen Reaktionen auch in in Deli
dann wenn man sich dann trifft und was
ich feststellt warte mal also die sind
ja gar nicht die stehen quasi dazwischen
und genau da wollen sie auch stehen ja
die Inder die wollen das nicht die
wollen sich nicht klar weder auf die
eine noch die andere Seite schlagen wie
sehr uns das verstört und was umgekehrt
zeigt wie unglaublich tief diese Art zu
denken ja bist du nicht für uns dann
bist du automatisch gegen uns ja wie
tief diese Art zu denken
dürfen wir nicht weiter denken wenn wir
weiter so denken führt uns das ins
Unheil also am militärisch und B
wirtschaftlich wir gewinnen nicht
dadurch dass der Punkt verstehst du wenn
es eine reale Chance gäbe freiheitswerte
in der Welt dadurch durchzusetzen wenn
es überhaupt eine reale Chance gebe dann
kann man darüber nachdenken aber diese
Chance gibt es nicht militärische
Konfrontation oder am besten noch
wirtschaftsbaukotte Sanktionen und was
weiß ich was führen doch nicht dazu dass
unsere Werte sich weiter ausbreiten wenn
man von denen so überzeugt ist wie ich
dann weiß man wie sensibel man mit
diesen Werten umgehen
es war also ich finde es auch
interessant
weil du gerade sagtest was da
stattgefunden hat ja so willkürliche
willkürliches ziehen von irgendwelchen
Sprachgrenzen oder auch politischen
Grenzen und so weiter so haben wir ja
unfassbar viele Fehler gemacht und Dinge
einfach laufen lassen obwohl wir wussten
dass sie falsch sind und so weiter wir
haben neulich über Moldawien gesprochen
für mich war der Überfall ja der Angriff
der der auf auf Moldau durch durch
Russland das war ehrlich gesagt irgendwo
so eine Randnotiz ja aber im Bewusstsein
der Moldauer sitzt das ganz tief drin ja
dieser dieses transistrieren dieser
eingefrorene Konflikt das klingt dann so
verharmlosen so als vermisst sich so
beschönigend ein eingefrorener Konflikt
der den wir in einer Tiefkühltruhe und
das Hähnchen das da drin komisch ist ja
ja von wegen das waren richtig harter
Krieg die haben die angegriffen und das
haben sich die Moldauer gemerkt und sie
haben sich auch gemerkt dass wir so
getan haben als wären nichts ja aber
Ungleichheit können wir nicht überall in
der Welt wo so etwas ist ja mal kurz die
gucken was er im Augenblick im Sudan
abläuft dann könnte ich jetzt meine
Karte machen wo es ist wir würden uns ja
völlig überanstrengen wenn wir jetzt
überall westliche Werte in der Welt
ernsthaft durchsetzen wollten mal
abgesehen davon dass natürlich ganz ganz
viele Länder gibt die diese westlichen
Werte auch gar nicht haben wollen
ja auch das ja das war ja zum Beispiel
das was wir kritischerweise beim
arabischen Frühling erleben mussten da
haben wir doch auch gedacht jetzt müssen
diese blöden Diktatoren da weg ja in
Libyen Gaddafi und das ist doch eine
gute Sache Tunesien und in Ägypten im
hubarak der so lange unserer Freund war
und von einem Tag auf den anderen nicht
mehr und das hat weg und so und dann
wird das so westlich demokratisch mein
Gott wir mussten daraus lernen ja
offensichtlich will die Mehrheit dieser
Menschen in diesen Ländern gar nicht
westlich demokratisch liberal und so
weiter werden sondern die wollen wie die
Inder die wollen ihren eigenen
arabischen Weg wie auch immer gehen ich
stelle mir immer die Frage was passiert
und ich glaube das dass ich ich bin
jetzt nicht Prophet spielen ne was
passiert wenn das molaregime in sich
zusammenfällt wenn das implodiert und
ich habe immer noch die Hoffnung dass
das in absehbarer Zeit passiert
wer kommt dann im Iran an die Macht und
was wird dann passieren es wird genau
dasselbe passieren es wird der Westen
also Europäer noch viel stärker die
Amerikaner umgekehrt die Russen die
Inder und so weiter versuchen so wie ein
Fluss wie möglich auf den zukünftigen
Iran zu gewinnen
ihn auf ihre Seite
in ihrem Land zu machen genau das wird
passieren die Bevölkerung wird in dieser
Frage höchstgespalten sein das heißt
also das entsteht dann die Gefahr eines
langfristigen Bürgerkrieges
und die wahre Antwort darauf ist was ist
denn das Beste für den Iran einen
eigenen Weg zu gehen einen eigenen Weg
zu gehen indem man sieht wie man mit den
anderen Großmächten in dieser Welt
halbwegs korrekt und zum eigenen Vorteil
umgeht ja aber werden wir das zulassen
oder werden wir wieder sagen Moment
Moment Moment wenn ihr nicht zu uns
gehört dann gehört er irgendwie zu denen
und werden wir nicht mit Milliarden
Aufwand bestimmte Strömungen und Gruppen
dann im Iran unterstützen was dann
vielleicht zu einem langenburger Krieg
führt und so weiter wie wäre es mit
nicht Einmischung wie wäre es der mit
dem Iran das Recht und die Chance zu
geben den eigenen Weg das ist total
interessante in diesem Zustand was dann
passiert weil ich wünsche mir aus aus
tiefstem Herzen und ich kenne viele
Iraner und ich bin mit Iranern
befreundet und das Thema wir haben doch
schon mal drüber gesprochen genau dass
wir dem Iran die Chance geben den
eigenen Weg zu gehen
ich fürchte habe dass wir das nicht tun
werden
total interessant ich meine es gibt eine
Blaupause eine historische Blaupause
dafür ne ich meine die Inder haben sich
das gemerkt Pakistan die USA haben
Pakistan seit der Gründung 47 auf
verschiedensten Ebenen massiv
unterstützt ja und und ich habe Thomas
gemacht ja und haben den geholfen und
die die Inder haben sich das gemerkt und
sagen Europa hätte Pakistan nicht helfen
dürfen ja der Terrorismus wurde von
Pakistan aus unterstützt und Pakistan
konnte seine ganzen terroristischen
Aktivitäten in und auch gegen Indien
Kaschmir und so weiter dass das
Stichwort ja nur machen
westliche Unterstützung hatte ganz genau
und wie hätten das nicht so laufen
lassen dürfen und immer wenn es in
Kaschmir brannte ja dann dann war im
Grunde Pakistan dafür verantwortlich so
sehen die in der das ja
kannst du mir gehört aber zu Indien so
ist es normal das gleiche auch
interessant weil du gerade arabischer
Frühling sagtest
auch etwas was man muss sich immer in
die Schuhe der anderen Stellen ne dann
wird es richtig interessant der
Einmarsch im Irak
durch die USA und Großbritannien vor
allen Dingen das haben die sich auch
genau angeguckt
Toni Blair 2003 genau und sagen
das fanden wir nicht so richtig knorke
weil Saddam Hussein war ein Freund
Indiens so sehen die das das sagen die
auch so und sagen das war ein riesiger
Fehler und es war auch eine Invasion so
wie in der Ukraine
wenn Europa genau Russland vorwirft in
Ukraine ein zu marschieren dann sagen
wir was habt ihr denn im Irak gemacht so
empfinden dass die Kinder total
interessant sich mal sozusagen in diese
Schuhe zu stellen und dann versteht man
plötzlich wie unterschiedlich man auf
die Welt gucken kann ne ja das ist ja so
wir bewerten völkerrechtsbrüche
unterschiedlich je nachdem wer sie
begeht ja und wenn es die USA sind mit
dem wir politisch befreundet sind dann
gehen wir nachsichtiger damit um als
wenn die Russen das machen so das ist
jetzt aus einer Reihe von Gründen auch
erstmal verständlich oder erklärlich nur
wenn wir das durchgehen lassen
dann haben wir sozusagen die moralische
Lizenz nicht mehr völkerrechtsbrüche in
dem Maße zu verurteilen wie sie
verurteilt werden müssen und andere
Länder so ein anderes Verhältnis zu den
USA haben sie in den einen
Völkerrechtsbruch auf derselben Ebene
wie den anderen Völkerrechtsbruch
ja also aus indischer Perspektive ja ist
es ist natürlich ist in die Ebene auch
die Chinesen sehen den Völkerrechtsbruch
und die unterstützen den auch nicht ja
aber sie wollen nicht dass der Westen
von der Situation profitiert
das ist ihr eigenes Interesse daran
abgesehen davon dass sie von Russland
billige Rohstoffe haben wollen Gas die
Chinesen Öl die Kinder und so weiter
aber das Wichtigste für sie ist dass die
Weltordnung sich nicht zugunsten der USA
wieder ein Stück verschiebt das ist ihr
Interesse daran
was willst du sagen abschließend Richard
wird die Welt jetzt ungemütlicher
wahrscheinlich ja aber steckt darin auch
eine Chance oder ist das eigentlich nur
Risiko was da gerade passiert also ich
glaube wie es im Augenblick gerade läuft
schief
und ich hoffe dass wir zur Besinnung
kommen und dass wir aus dieser weißt du
kriegerische Kriege fangen mit Rhetorik
an
rhetorischem aufrüsten mit klarer Freund
feindlinien Markierung ja total ja mit
weltanschaulicher Aufladung der eigenen
Positionen richtig ja also man man
richtet sich ja da in einem Palast von
Begriffen ein wie in einer Festung und
wusstet erstmal gegen den anderen auf
und hier wünsche ich mir Achtsamkeit
Abrüstung Vorsicht ja also zu merken
wenn die Situation so gefährlich ist wie
sie im Augenblick wird mehr und mehr
dann müssen wir anfangen wieder
vorsichtiger zurück zu rudern und so
weiter und nicht in die ganze Sache da
noch mit mit zusätzlicher Brand Rhetorik
reinzugehen wir haben diese schreckliche
Katastrophe diesen russischen
Angriffskrieg wir haben diesen
Völkerrechtsbruch wir haben das Morgen
vor der Haustür und so weiter das jetzt
noch stärker auszuweiten in einen global
Konflikt der Demokrat Strategien gegen
die Autokratien und so weiter wohin soll
das führen ich glaube wir bewegen uns in
die falsche Richtung
es ist auf jeden Fall interessant
mal die Perspektive zu wechseln mal zu
verstehen dass es
nicht mehr diese Welt ist die so klar
schwarz-weiß ist sondern dass da auch
sehr viel grau dazwischen ist
und also erstmal zu verstehen dass wir
also der Westen ja nicht Blüten weiß
sind ja das auch moralisch makellos
richtig ja und die anderen nicht alle
ich rede jetzt von China ja also in
erster Linie dass die nicht tief schwarz
sind und rot sowieso nicht
also das als allererstes mal zu
verstehen bei dir auch uns in
historischen Zeiträumen bewegen weil wir
die anderen ist die Geschichte nicht
vorbei weißt du wenn du 40 Jahre alt
bist und das Gefühl hast wir sind doch
hier die guten und wir leben mehr
freiheitlich liberalen Demokratie und
das ist alles klasse also können wir die
anderen auch was sagen oder belehren
dann vergisst du eine Geschichte die für
dich Vergangenheit ist die aber in den
anderen Ländern noch fort lebt wie zum
Beispiel die Kolonialgeschichte der
Engländer Franzosen ja aber weißt du was
die Kolonialgeschichte wird häufig
angeführt ich denke ja manchmal ganz
ehrlich ich meine wir also der Westen
wir haben einen Typen wie Trump ins
Weiße Haus gewählt wir haben Boris
Johnson street number ten untergebracht
ja was diese Leute dort alles
veranstaltet haben brexit und so weiter
in welches Chaos die angerichtet haben
und das haben wir über den sechsten
Januar Kapitol und so weiter noch gar
nicht gesprochen also da sind wir doch
die letzten die sich hinstellen können
und sagen können was auf also in der
Werte leeren die man alles richtig genau
und gewaltfrei genauso macht man das
bitteschön sag mal ein zum Schluss ein
kleines gedankenspiel also ein Typ wie
Trump wird US-Präsident oder die Säntis
und es würde tatsächlich das Worst Case
Szenario eintreten dass ich jetzt nicht
glaube nur als Gedankenspiel die würden
die demokratischen Institutionen in den
USA aushöhlen ja und so nach Putin schon
Muster zu pappt Demokratie werden und
wir sagen im 21 jahrhunderts geht es
wertegeleitet um den Kampf der
Demokratien gegen die Autokratien
dann wären die USA nicht wenn unser
Verbündeter sondern genauso wie China
als Autokratie und Russland als
autokorativ
unser Freund
würden wir dann außenpolitisch komplett
umschwenken und uns von den USA
distanzieren und sagen mit Autokratien
haben wir nichts zu schaffen
ist doch völlig klar was die Antwort ist
wir sind von den USA wirtschaftlich
immer noch genauso abhängiger
militärisch völlig abhängig von den Hose
wir würden es nicht tun und wenn wir
schon wissen dass wir das nicht tun dann
erkennen wir auch daran dass die
Begriffe Autokratie und Demokratie als
Gegenbegriffe so ernst gar nicht gemeint
sind sie verbrennen Interessen
das war spannend wird auch nicht das
letzte Mal gewesen sein dass wir uns
darüber unterhalten danke sehr ich danke
dir auch einen guten Tag ja du auch
eine Produktion von m hoch 2 und potsdas
bei OMR im Auftrag des ZDF
[Musik]